نحن في الجولان المحتل تزداد خشيه اسرائيل
كثيرا في الفتره الاخيره من امكان ان
تستغل ايران مساعدتها للروس في الحرب على
اوكرانيا لجهه تكثيف التموضع الايراني
داخل الجغرافيا السوريه لهذا التوقعات في
اسرائيل بتكثيف الغرض ضد المواقع
الايرانيه الداخله سوريا لكن لا يقلق
اسرائيل اكثر من ذلك حاليا هو محاوله
محتمله من ايران وفقا بعض المصادر الامنيه
في اسرائيل بتهريب
تقنيات اسلحه دقيقه عبر مطار بيروت لصالح
حزب الله ما قد يؤدي في محاوله اعتراض ذلك
الى حرب شامله مع حزب الله على جبهته
لبنان كما سوري سوريا
وفي الوقت الذي تقول في اسرائيل بان ايران
طلبت من روسيا عوده الامور الى ما كانت
عليه قبل العام 2019 اي اطلاق يد ايران
تماما تموضعا ونفودا داخل سوريا وذلك ايضا
بوضع بطاريات دفاع جويه ايرانيه جديده بدل
تلك الروسيه عمليا على الارض بدات اسرائيل
باستعدادات لحرب المحتمله على هذه الجبهه
من قبيل انشاء مناطق عازله كما في هذه
المنطقه في جباته الخشب حيث توغلت اسرائيل
وانشات شوارع امنيه داخل القرى السوريه
وجرفت بعض المزارع اللافت اكثر بان
اسرائيل اعلن عن مناورات عسكريه شامله في
المنطقه الشماليه تحاكم دلاع حرب متعدده
الجبهات زياد حلبي العربيه الجولان المحتل